今天要聊的這個案例我覺得很有意思。想像一下，你投入三萬美金，然後幾乎不用管，你的電商每月就能有六位數營收。
六位數月營收？這聽起來有點出乎意料，怎麼說呢？通常做電商不是都要自己找貨、客服、處理物流嗎？這怎麼可能「不用管」？
對啊，這就是重點。這個案例說的是，有位三十多歲的客戶，她四年前拿了三萬美金給 Elite Automation 這家公司，希望她的錢能自動幫她賺錢，但又不想變成第二份工作。
喔，所以不是她自己去經營電商，而是找了一家公司幫她全權管理？這不就變成一種投資了嗎？
沒錯，你可以這樣理解。Elite Automation 提供的服務是「完全託管的 Amazon 電商門店」。他們不是賣你一個電商生意，也不做一般人想像的直銷。
那他們具體做什麼？幫客戶做什麼？
他們的團隊負責採購、履行訂單、定價，還有日常的帳戶管理。客戶擁有這個 Amazon 帳戶，擁有營收流，也擁有這個數位資產。公司負責營運，客戶就不用自己動手。
這樣一來，客戶就真的只是出錢，然後等著收錢。聽起來有點像買房地產然後租出去，但不用自己當包租公？
其實就是這個概念。原文裡特別提到，這跟一般創業要花時間去經營的「副業」不同。這是一個「託管的數位資產」，它需要你的資本，然後就讓開，不佔用你的時間。
那這種模式能撐多久？實際數字真的這麼好嗎？我猜啦，這是不是短期衝高銷量，長期就不行了？
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。以最近的四月份來說，總銷售額是 165,291.14 美元，售出 3,084 件商品，淨利潤是 25,344.03 美元，投資報酬率有 22.10%。
等等，這是四年前投入三萬美金，現在一個月淨利潤就兩萬五美金？這回報率很高啊！
不只這樣，原文說這還不是特例。前兩個月也差不多是六位數營收，淨利潤也都在五位數，投資報酬率維持在 10% 到 20% 之間。這是四年持續營運下來的成果。
所以這不是一次性的成功，而是靠長期、有紀律的流程重複累積出來的。這點其實不容易做到。
是啊。所以對於創業者或中小企業主來說，這個案例我覺得很有啟發。它展示了一種「服務即產品」的新商業模式。如果你有某項專業技能，例如電商營運、行銷或財務規劃，是不是也能包裝成這種「託管服務」？
的確，把專業知識變成一種讓客戶「省時省力」的資產，而不是一次性的諮詢服務，這是一個不同的思路。那如果是一般上班族，這概念能怎麼應用到工作或生活上呢？
我在想，上班族也可以從中學習「時間配置」的概念。我們是不是常常把所有精力都投入在單一工作或投資上？原文提到，這位客戶的 Amazon 電商門店，成了她除了房地產、股票和主要事業之外的「第四個支柱」。
也就是說，這提供了一種「多元化」的思考。不只是金錢上的多元投資，也包括時間和精力上的多元配置，減少對單一收入來源的依賴。
對，而且它強調的是「託管資產」，讓錢或某些專案自動運轉，而不是凡事都要親力親為。這可能也提醒了我們，有時候，讓專業的人做專業的事，效果反而會更好。